das geschäft mit den koks taxen boomt in
deutschlands großstädten eine anruf eine
sms oder telegramm nachricht genügt und
binnen weniger minuten steht der dealer
vor der haustür
mit einem großaufgebot drückt die
polizei gleichzeitig an mehreren orten
der hauptstadt an
ermittler sagen noch nie ist so viel
kokain auf dem markt gewesen und noch
nie war es einfacher an den stoff heran
zu kommen in metropolen wie hier in
berlin macht man es mittlerweile so
einfach das handy rausgeholt eine
nachricht geschrieben und schon kommt
ein sogenanntes koks taxi vorgefahren
lilly von der osten nico nelken und
tillmann mit recherchen über diesen
kriminellen dieser service
berlin 14 dezember 6 uhr in der früh
razzia im morgengrauen mit einem
großaufgebot drückt die polizei
gleichzeitig an mehreren orten der
hauptstadt an durchsucht 14 gebäude
zwölf autos sogar zellen der jva sitzen
die ermittler im mittelpunkt der razzia
ein berliner clown der koks taxis
organisiert und damit millionen verdient
das spezialkommando nimmt vier männer
fest zwei tatverdächtige sitzen bereits
wegen koks taxis im gefängnis ein
weiterer täter ist auf der flucht
stehen im verdacht sich
zusammengeschlossen zu haben
berlin 26 november ein uhr nachts am
alexanderplatz stoppen zivile fahnder
zwei jugendliche in einem auto zuvor
beobachten die ermittler immer wieder
personen die in den kleinwagen des duos
einsteigen und nach wenigen minuten das
auto verlassen ein koks taxi die
polizisten stellen abgepacktes kokain
weitere drogen und bargeld sicher
festnahme
[Musik]
das geschäft mit den koks taxen boomt in
deutschlands großstädten eine anruf eine
sms oder telegramm nachricht genügt und
binnen weniger minuten steht der dealer
vor der haustür und seit der pandemie
läuft das geschäft besonders gut noch
nie zuvor konsumierten die deutschen so
viel kokain wie im jahr 2021 und was
macht die politik vergangenes jahr
interviewen bild-reporter die damalige
bundesdrogenbeauftragte da muss ich
jetzt mal die berliner wirklich loben
die polizei es voll rein gegangen sofort
gegen diese sogenannten cox taxis hat
schnell reagiert sehr intensiv
kontrolliert mit der folge dass es die
kuckucks taxis jetzt nicht mehr gibt
wirklich wir machen den test
hier in berlin jetzt dutzende gruppen
auf tele bärn pr-coup bis vor die
haustür liefern 9 und die anderen ganz
harmlose namen wie beispielsweise die
candy shop oder flut store wir gehen
jetzt mal in einen dieser gruppen rhein
zum beispiel heißt one stop für linz da
kann man in ganz berlin bestellen
zwischen zwölf und ein ruhe- und ja die
anbieter werben mit schneller und
sicherer lieferung drei
mindestbestellwert von 50 euro
um das ganze zu bestellen gehe ich hier
auf den geheimen chat und schreibe jetzt
einfach dem anbieter der vor drei
minuten zuletzt online war
und er antwortet ich schon schreibt
direkt klar
so er hat mir jetzt das menü geschickt
und ich frage einfach mal wie schnell
kannst du in berlin-mitte sein
so jetzt gibt er wieder schreibt sehr
schnell und will die adresse direkt
haben nur ein paar klicks und das kokain
wäre geliefert doch nicht nur telegramm
ist bei den dealern beliebt besonders
dreist sogar visitenkarten verteilen die
drogenkuriere inzwischen an ihre
potentielle kundschaft
plötzlich vor zwei tagen in mitte
unterwegs war wurde mir ein junger mann
kokain an in einer bar und jetzt
versuche ich mal dort anzurufen zu
schauen ob diese nummer überhaupt noch
geht
hallo hier ist hallo ich habe die
risiken karte bekommen vor zwei tagen
ja und ich wollte gerne obst kaufen
ich bin jetzt in kreuzberg
ok und werden das sind also die preise
oder besprechen wir das dann
der weg vom koks taxi zum konsumenten
ist der letzte kleine schritt auf einem
langen weg hinter dem kokain steckt ein
weltweit agierendes kriminelles netzwerk
hauptproduzenten des kokains sind die
südamerikanischen länder peru bolivien
und kolumbien auf containerschiffen
transportieren kartelle die süchtig
machende droge über den atlantik geht es
beispielsweise zum hamburger hafen im
großen stil kaufen sich dort kriminelle
clans ein und beliefern ihr deutsches
netzwerk die fahrer der koks taxis sind
in den meisten fällen nur kleine
handlanger der organisierten
kriminalität
für einen geringen anteil am gewinn
liefern sie koks rund um die uhr und die
clubbosse kassieren ab im jahr 2009 10
wurde in berlin täglich mehr als vier
kilogramm kokain konsumiert bei einem
straßenverkaufswert von 100 euro
programm macht das 400.000 euro pro tag
vierzehnter dezember an einem geheimen
ort in bayern verbrennen polizisten 15
tonnen sichergestellte kokain marktwert
auf den straßen deutschlands 270
millionen euro in bananenkisten
schmuggelten kartelle die drogen ins
land um sie hier von einem albanischen
clan weiter verkaufen zu lassen ich
halte hier in meiner hand an diesem
pokalsiege und die täterseite hat in
unserem ermittlungsverfahren paraguay
diese ziegel in bananenkisten
eingebracht und im selben menge wie die
ziegel in die befüllten bananenkisten
eingebracht wurden wurden die früchte
entnommen so dass es nicht auffällt vom
gewicht her dass da was anderes drin ist
als ursprünglich vorgesehen
lagerarbeiter eines supermarktes fanden
das rauschgift kurz danach nehmen die
beamten die albanischen drogenbosse fest
die dealer im knast das kokain in der
müllverbrennungsanlage zwei tage später
in hamburg auch zollfahnder präsentieren
stolz ihre beute 360 kilogramm kokain
welches sie in einer trauben küste aus
beruf hin verpasst der gewinn der koks
dealer 40 millionen euro
[Musik]
bayern hamburg und berlin
fahndungserfolge doch der kampf gegen
den kokainhandel scheint endlos
insbesondere durch die einfache
verfügbarkeit des rauschgifts floriert
das geschäft
es dauert nicht mal eine minute dann
fährt der fahrer des taxis zu mir los
und bringt die tür allein in berlin
liefen bis mitte november bereits 728
ermittlungsverfahren gegen verdächtige
im zusammenhang mit koks taxen 55 x
durchsuchen ermittler gebäude mehr als
30 mal klicken die handschellen
doch die party scheint kein ende zu
finden